more than a hundred thousand dead
livelihoods lost
and a generation put at risk with no
clear end in sight
and a prime minister unable to announce
a way out of the third national lockdown
only give a date of when a plan might
emerge
we remain in a perilous situation
with more than 37 000 patients now in
hospital with covid
almost double the peak of the first wave
but the overall picture should be
clearer by mid-february
by then we will know much more about the
effect of vaccines
in preventing hospitalizations and
deaths
the caveat being if no new covert
variants emerge
and the vaccine rollout continues as
planned
the lockdown is particularly tough on
children school closures have led to
mental health plummeting
and inequality soaring the government
says classrooms may reopen
on march 8th but it will take years for
students to catch up on lost education
meanwhile new quarantine rules for some
arrivals into the uk
to try and protect the country from
unknown covert mutations
uk citizens and residents flying in from
22 countries
will be forced to isolate in hotels for
10 days at their own expense
the high-risk countries include south
africa and brazil
where covert variants are already
circulating
we have also banned all travel from 22
countries where there is a risk of known
variants
including south africa portugal and
south american
nations and in order to reduce the risk
posed by uk nationals and residents
returning home from these countries
i can announce that we will require all
such arrivals who cannot be refused
entry to isolate in government provided
accommodation
such as hotels for 10 days without
exception
the airline industry says with no exit
plan these measures will effectively
close the uk's borders
and argue the country already has strict
protocols in place
while some ministers wanted to
quarantine every traveller
we need a much stronger defenses at our
borders
we were one of the slowest countries to
take any measures on our borders
when we had a quarantine system not many
people were checked and here we are
today
without a comprehensive way of
protecting our borders
that at the very least is urgently
needed
vaccines are providing hope for many but
the uk has the highest death toll in
europe
the prime minister insists he has
followed the science throughout the
pandemic yet the scientists
disagree and grimly predict another 50
000 people could die charlie angela al
jazeera